hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
it's a fifth of August and you are tuned
in to gamespot news metal gear publisher
Konami have posted their earnings for
the last quarter and given they manage
473 million bucks in revenue I'd say
they did pretty well the company saw a
jump of a hundred and forty five point
six percent from last year and that's
due in part to konami successful mobile
games and the continual steady sales of
metal gear solid 5 ground zeroes the
latter has now shipped more than 1
million copies the vast majority of
units sold with the ps3 and ps4 which
made up fifty-four percent of konami
sternal game sales xbox 360 and xbox one
sales only made up twelve percent in
terms of upcoming Konami games the
company said they intend to the games to
match the characteristics of each
platform a new assassin's creed game is
coming out and it's ps3 and xbox 360
exclusive Assassin's Creed rogue is
coming on November 11 from Bulgaria base
to do Ubisoft Sofia in collaboration
with other international Ubisoft studios
the game is set in the mid 18th century
during the seven years war in North
America you play as an assassin turns
Templar named shay Patrick Cormac and
this installment is debt to bridge the
gap between the American AC saga and
black flag does ship sailing hoods that
come down super fast wheat grass
graphics and a crap ton of tundra or
wrapped around the scene of shape
betraying another assassin possibly his
mentor in things that are hilarious to
say resident evil remake is getting a
remaster fantastic Capcom is releasing
the amped-up version from microsoft and
sony's current and last generation
consoles as well as for pc the
remastered version of the gamecube
remake includes enhancements such as an
improvement character models and
backgrounds a scrolling camera that
helps to convert the games 4 by 3
presentation to 16 by 9 and the option
to use analog stick controls all the
original aneurysm olicity
tank controls Capcom are happy for you
to switch off the sixteen by nine as
well if you just want the original
experience lasts up hugely anticipated
co-op shooter evolved has been delayed
till 2015 originally scheduled for an
October 21 release date the game is now
set to hit shelves on februari 10 of
next year then users trickled down as
part of 2k parent company take to spine
natural results announcement so no
reason has been given for the delay as
yet 2k had previously said that evolve
would be a defining xbox one and ps4
game of 2014 so perhaps it'll be a
defining game of next year instead we'll
keep you updated with any new info on
the delay as it comes out ask me a
question of the day let me know down in
that comment section if you're more
excited to play the resident evil
remaster or assassin's creed rogue those
are all the things i wanted to tell you
about today i'll be back same time
tomorrow but as usual thanks for tuning
in